hi and welcome to episode number 28 of
the weekly Google klappa from podcast
I'm Franciscan point and I'm here with
my colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
France sku doing today very good very
good a very interested with the main
content of the week yeah we're we're
moving away from some of the shiny
things sort of stepping away from
container stepping away from App Engine
going like let's just talk about VMs
yeah what is a virtual machine how do
you use them a google how are better
hours than authors etc I think it's
gonna be very interesting we're gonna
have um what's his name scott van wooden
Burke will be our bus wouldn't work yes
and a very good pronunciation of that
one but I thank you every working on my
pronunciation yeah so yeah we're gonna
we're gonna have him and then afterwards
we can have a question of the week that
comes from one of our listeners no I'm
Franco on he's looking at how we can
connect datastore backups to bigquery
yeah exactly so yeah we're gonna we're
gonna end up doing that question of the
week at the end of the episode but
before we have a cool thing of the week
yeah we have this really great you knew
you'd asset e-course from two of our
team members Kelsey Hightower and cada
Morgan who have done a communities
online Udacity course yep and it is
pretty amazing just because seeing those
two people working together is is there
a vm again they're there they're really
really fun but also basically it's gonna
take you from the basics to what is a
container and how how do you use them to
generate well to create microservices to
then create your own ADIZ clusters and
then deploy microservices on them and
basically everything from scratch to
having your own micro services running
on the cloud yeah and best of all it's
very oh yeah absolutely it's absolutely
free which is awesome and you can find a
link on our show notes yeah yeah it
should be very interesting to get done
yeah I'm definitely going to go through
it just
i'm i'm pretty sure i know most of it
I'm sure we'll learn some of some new
stuff yeah but I think it's just gonna
be fun to see them presenting yeah that
sounds really really good cool so what
do you think should we go talk to Scott
that sounds like a great idea let's talk
about virtual machines we are joined
today by Scott Van wooden Berg p.m. on
compute engine Scott how are you doing
today good doing well thanks guys thanks
for having on absolutely before we get
stuck into what you do at Google and
like the products you work on might you
tell us a little bit about yourself and
your role and all that sort of fun stuff
sure so I'm a product manager on Google
compute engine which is our
infrastructure as a service offering
which is part of our broader Google
cloud platform before Google I was about
spent about 16 years as a software
engineer and engineering lead and
manager kind of moving up the chain on
the on the engineering side of the house
before I decided to switch to product
management so I came to Google in 2012
to be a PM on compute engine and I've
been doing it ever since right around
the time i joined like basically weeks
after a few weeks after i joined GCE was
announced publicly for the first time we
kind of announced our we called a
limited preview at the time but it's
basically our alpha launch at that
year's Google i/o so it's been a very
exciting ride to ride the exponential
growth curve that we've seen since since
we started and especially since we g8
back in 2013 excellent all right
wonderful well thanks so much for
joining us well let's sort of start at
the most basic level that we can what is
a virtual machine like I'm sure a lot of
our listeners probably have a bit of an
idea but like I think let's listen to go
let's go as simple as possible what is
it yeah so this is actually I said this
is kind of a tough answered tough
question to answer tersely I guess or
succinctly I spent a little time kind of
researching and ticket took a look at
what Wikipedia had to say about it and
kind of the most basic definition I
could find was a essentially a virtual
machine as a software implementation of
a physical computer or server so and
then obviously on Wikipedia there was it
was followed by a few
like fairly low-level technical detail
on virtualization on hypervisors on para
virtualized devices on yeah this goes on
and on and then you know along with
about a you know two dozen reference
links down at the bottom where you could
go read about more detail so I kind of
step back and thought about and I think
you know for the purposes of this
discussion and just kind of for cloud
customers that were looking at GCE or
look comparing it against ec2 or just
trying to understand maybe you come from
an app engine background or you're a
front-end developer or you know for you
know depending on where you coming from
it's best just to kind of think of a vm
as a trusted ubiquitous computing
environment that lets you decouple the
actual code that runs from the hardware
that it runs on so think of it as an
abstraction layer that is both secure
and ubiquitous which is which are kind
of the 22 things that have made virtual
machines you know as popular as they are
so like containers so containers is
actually a very light that is a
excellent example of a computing
abstraction that is not yet very secure
and but and it is also not yet quite as
ubiquitous as virtual machines there
will be a day sometime down the road
where all of the security issues get
worked out like you can have complete
isolation between two containers running
on the same host and and there'll be a
very secure trusted sandbox is kind of
how we think about these these
environments computing abstraction
layers run in the sandbox is kind of
like a JVM kind of like you know like
any interpreted language has like a
runtime environment and you know that
runtime environment that sandbox has to
be proven to be secure and you know pasa
it's impossible for one container to
break out of that sandbox environment to
to muck with the memory or you know
other area that different containers
environment so that you can have a true
multi-tenant computing platform which is
really what VMs gives you and the reason
why VMs is where is is because VMware
started this whole game you know 12 10
12 years ago
and has has basically you know taken the
taken the market by storm back in the
day before VMware everything ran just on
directly on hardware and VMware added
this virtualization abstraction and it
really took off but you know it's been
secured like they've been finding all
the bugs and making sure that it's
secure for the last 10 12 years so so
containers is just kind of at the
beginning of that curve I think so and
although that for security concerns that
you were mentioning why would someone
choose running at vm using google
compute engine rather than App Engine or
kubin at ease on container engine yeah
so I mean the the simplest answer is
because that's what like enterprises
anybody coming to the cloud that has
existing workloads either on Prem or on
AWS or elsewhere it's going to be like a
compute engine or you know
infrastructure as a service is going to
be the most familiar and you know
probably most like what they're
currently running especially enterprises
where most of them are running on in
their data centers or in colo
environments or whatever they're
probably using VMware the majority of
them are using VMware running virtual
machines so what they're familiar with
this is basically infrastructure is
going to be most customers on ramp into
the cloud and then once they're on the
cloud and they're they're out of the
business of managing their own data
centers like doing there you know three
or five-year Hardware refreshes and
dealing with all that stuff once they've
move those applications to the cloud all
utahn to GCE from there they'll then be
able to start decomposing rewriting
rewriting components kind of splitting
them out into micro services and taking
advantage of some of the other really
cool technologies that cloud platform
offers and not not not our cloud
platform obviously offers some really
amazing especially big data analytics
machine learning we've got a ton of
really amazing products that that
abstract that are built at a higher
level of abstraction like the machine
learning is basically an open source API
so you don't actually have to manage
underlying resources if you don't want
to that's that's the end Kuber Nettie's
is a great example of that where you
just write your code and you know right
right your containers like what you want
to implement in a container deployed as
a micro service and deploy dozens of
other ones and they
start talking to each other that's
really kind of the power there you don't
have to think about like the hardware
how much RAM how much how many cords
like am I using it efficiently all that
other stuff you just stop thinking about
it and that's the advantage of moving up
the stack but as far as getting
workloads onto the into cloud the the
first step the on ramp is going to be
GCE a pop from that sort of general
on-ramp to come into the cloud there any
particular use cases you see that people
are like Oh VMs are just much better for
this than say maybe some of the more
shiny technologies out there so I think
you know the it really kind of depends
on what people like to focus on like you
know at the end of the day virtual
machines give you absolute control over
every layer you know every piece of the
software you control you are the one
that writes all the code to do like auto
scaling up and down and and you know
basically scaling your ear the number of
VMs that you have based on the the
incoming demand and capacity is so
really for the for the very
sophisticated customers or applications
that need control over every aspect of
their of their application virtual
machines is probably going to continue
to be the the go to product or go to
technology for for some of those there's
also stuff like you know if you have to
run something like sequel server or
something like like a third-party
software package that that doesn't
really have like a containerized version
like or it doesn't it's not available
like to an app engine app like you know
like a video encoding library for
example like we have tons of App Engine
customers that basically use App Engine
to orchestrate to do the front-end
serving but then also to orchestrate
like kind of transcoding workloads like
media rendering that sort of thing and
and you know that's where they basically
break out of the App Engine layer use
GAE App Engine flex 2 to run GCE VMs but
still managed by App Engine and and
those vm is the only thing that you're
doing is pulling you know videos or
audio off of us queue and transcoding it
because you can actually run lib you
know live mm peg and the other
transcoding
libraries which are typically written in
c you can just run those in a vmware you
can't really run those in App Engine
without rewriting them as a Python
library or something like that which is
just too much work I think just went
exactly throw the architecture of a flat
spin have reason that I google i/o it
was exactly that yeah yeah yeah it's a
very popular very popular model and an
app engine makes it really App Engine
plus G App Engine flex make it really
easy to manage the vmsu still you you
know that they're there but but it
handles all of the orchestration and so
you don't have to anime it just makes it
super simple so I have one more question
regarding these trend towards containers
so you said that for vm is like a very
good place to when you're doing my
favorite phrase lift and shift to get
started on the cloud then some people
move to containers and what is your
opinion on these strand tours serverless
computing taking into account that all
your business is selling servers so
serverless is i mean there's there's a
couple interpretation so like 11
interpretation of what that means is i
just write code I don't have to think
about like the underlying deployment
orchestration I don't have to think
about you know how that that code gets
scaled up and scaled down to handle
increase load like the diurnal cycles
that sort of thing so you know it
basically just means that the the
product or whatever it is that I'm
programming against has abstracted away
the fact that under under the covers
there's servers that are connected over
networks and stuff like that so so
that's kind of you know one
interpretation another one is just look
I just have you know like kind of like
the cloud functions model or the AWS
lambda model where you're just writing
like these little snippets of code that
you need to run as when some trigger
comes in you know like I don't know like
I've just pushed a new request on to it
like an entry onto a task you I want
that to trigger a cloud function to run
and and pull that off the task you and
do something to it and then push it back
on to a different task queue or
something and that's really where you
know something like cloud functions
you really aren't even you're worried
about even less you just write a
function essentially what is it what
ends up being like a function in
whatever your favorite language is and
then that you hook it up you have me set
up a trigger and then you that function
goes off and does something which may
trigger other functions to run which you
know gives you this ability to kind of
just write individual functions hook
them all together and you end up
building like these kind of crazy
complicated applications that that never
have to touch you know and never have to
even think about like the notion of even
a container like it's completely
abstracted away even beyond that cool so
since we're talking about compute engine
and you are pretty much the expert on
the topic what are you favorite features
of GC so I think they're like a lot of
my favorite features come from like kind
of the underlying flexible
infrastructure that were built on so
like a two of my two of the best
examples and my you know personal
favorites are the per minute billing
that we have and then the automatic
sustained use discounts so permanent
billing you know most of the big
hyperscale cloud offerings right now
bill per the per hour so if you spin up
a virtual machine you run it for like 20
minutes and then you shut it down you
get charged for an entire hour for
computed on compute engine you only get
charged for those 20 minutes and then if
you start it up again and run it for you
know another 15 minutes then you only
get charged for those 15 minutes instead
of it being rounded up to an hour now we
do have a 10 minute minimum so if you
spend it up for three minutes you get
charged for 10 minutes but really you
know that's it's it's pretty significant
savings if if you're at if what you're
doing with the vm doesn't doesn't
typically take you know on the order of
multiple hours and and you know
obviously the longer the vm runs the
less of a less of impact or less of a
savings you get but that's where
sustained use discounts comes in which
is the longer you run the vm for a given
month the cheaper that vm the per hour
or per minute cost of that vm is so if
you run a vm 24-7 for an entire month
you basically get like 30 percent
discount off of the list price
for that entire month and we just kind
of at the end of the month we aggregate
all of your VMs up and do this do the
math to basically give you a discount
over all of the usage based on how long
those VMs rent a month and that's that's
all especially the permanent billing and
that's really kind of comes down to like
some of the like the flexible real-time
data processing infrastructure that we
have here at Google that lets us do you
know all near real-time billing and
monetization like that which is is you
know when you're talking about you know
the number of VMs that GCE runs on
behalf of their customers like doing per
minute billing up for all of those VMs
all the time is actually a pretty
significant data processing challenge
but that's the type of thing that
Google's good at and so we've leveraged
that some of that in-house expertise to
solve it another of my favorite features
is custom machine types that's basically
when you go to create a VM you typically
specify and into what's called an
instance type or a machine-type and that
that basically is kind of the hardware
spec like the virtual hardware spec of
the vm so it's the number of cores you
want how much RAM you want and basically
what GCE offers that none of the major
competitors offer is the ability to
customize that like you know what I
don't need you know I don't need a 8
cores but four cores is too small so I'm
going to create a six-core xeon and i
happen to know that i need two gigs
percorso i'm going to create a 6-core
12-game bite of ram virtual machine
using custom machine types and that lets
me save money over the next highest up
so actually let me take a quick step
back like we also like GCE as well as
the other major public clouds give you a
selection of predefined instance types
of machine types so you know Google
calls them like n one standard one and
one high mem for etc Anna the standard
Haim my cpu really just refers to the
RAM decor ratio competitors offer like
AWS offers the C 3 4 x large c 4 2
x-large exciter etc so there's these
predefined machine types that you get
that you have to choose from but if your
work glove doesn't fit
exactly into like it's too small for the
four like a c4 2x large but too small
for a c4 x-large are too big for a c4
x-large you know there's no you
basically have to buy the how the next
size up or you have to figure out how to
tailor your workload so that it fits
exactly into one of those predefined
shapes and that's where custom machine
types really shines is the ability to
tailor the vm shape to the workload not
vice versa and that's especially
important for enterprises coming to the
cloud because they've probably what
they're probably running on is like a
dell server that's got some number of
cores and some amount of ram and that's
basically you know their homogeneous
fleet that they've they've run they're
running right now for all these
different applications and instead of
having to kind of scratch their heads
and figure out how to you know adjust
the workload so that it fits in with one
of these predefined types they just go
create a custom machine type that
exactly mimics what they have on Prem
and they're off to the races it's one
less you know kind of pain point or
friction point when moving to GCE from
an existing on-prem environment and that
would seem to me as well like a really
nice cost savings as well I know I do
some stuff with gaming companies and so
often they want like necessarily a whole
lot of RAM but they don't necessarily
need like the fastest cpu in the world
so when you're in that sort of cookie
cutter world and you have to have both
of those at the same time this is a nice
way to say hey no we don't need that
much CPU that's fine lots of RAM so we
can we can really tailor spend our money
exactly where we need it yes exactly
yeah there's one of the things you've
been talking a lot about the flexibility
of our infrastructure and one of the
places where I think it shows is the
fact that we're able to reside precise /
persistent disks while the instance is
running and the disk is attached to it
yep that is something that first time I
showed to a customer they were impressed
with that it was I hope how is this
magic yes that work yeah that's that's
funny that was something that we
launched fairly recently and I don't
think it's I don't think it's really
kind of hit the kind of customer so that
meant psyche or whatever you want to
kind of collective customer psyche
because it is a super powerful feature
and the customers that have encountered
you know there's a lot of issues that
happen
that that could cause you're like
especially like your root boot partition
to fill up I like your boot PD like
typically we only allocate like you know
10 gigs worth or 20 gigs worth you keep
those small because you don't put any
data on them and stuff like that but
still you know any most guest OS dumped
like all of their logging information on
there etc and so if for whatever reason
you're not paying attention you don't
have any alert set up and the root
volume fills up with like log data or
something then all of a sudden you're
now no longer able the ssh into your vm
because the ssh relies on being able to
write its own logs and when it that
fails like everything fails basically
and and that's this is like common not
just on this is basically any linux any
you know server that runs if you fill up
the root partition bad things happen and
this Reese I hot resize is just a super
easy and quick way to be like oh crap i
had a runaway log script or something
and my volumes filled up let me just go
into the UI click two buttons and double
the size of the pd root pd volume so i
can go in and you know fix my spammy log
file or fix whatever it is that's
filling up the root partition like it's
just it's such a convenient and and
powerful mechanism and it's not just
related to root volumes obviously like
if you've got data volumes that you know
let's say you you use GCS connector to
pull a bunch of data from GCS to a local
vm to do to run a to a bunch of VMS pds
to do a Hadoop job and all you know
you're writing out the results and all
of a sudden the job fails because the
data disk that you were riding out to is
full you know what like you just go
resize again just go resize the disk and
rerun the job and all of a sudden you
you're you're you're good to go you
don't have to stop the vm you don't have
to shut everything down and detach it
and resize it or create a bigger one and
copy everything it's just it's just
super super powerful yeah you could even
consider doing that through the API so
you they need to even up just click a
single button just everything happens
yeah just amazing set up set up a stack
Driver Alert that automate that triggers
a you know sack Driver Alert that when
it gets ninety percent full you know
call a cloud function that calls the GCE
API that
size of the disk up doubles the size of
the disk so many cloud things yes pretty
sure I'd teammate terry has a little
script that he can see demo'd showing
off doing exactly that where it nice
keeps track of how much data you've got
and how much free space you have and
then if it runs out it's like oh I'm
just gonna double your petition here
yeah I'm fine but you might want to look
at this at some point to figure out why
it's filling up but in the meantime just
gonna go fix it yeah that's really cool
and I think that touches on some other
stuff too like for example we can do a
bunch of stuff to your infrastructure as
it's running like you want to look a
little bit about live migrations and how
that works yeah sure so you know the one
of the biggest challenges for a cloud
provider is keeping the software and
hardware infrastructure that that that
all the VMS run on keeping it up-to-date
keeping it patch secure rolling out new
versions of all the different layers of
that stack etc and you know if it's
something significant like upgrading the
host Colonel that that is running on the
server that your VMs are running on like
obviously that's a very you know
disruptive action for or anything that's
running on that house you basically have
to like you know take everything off the
host what we call drain we have to drain
the host and and do the upgrade and then
reboot it and it comes up on the new
kernel that's all like and so what with
in that reality and the reality of
maintaining these systems and keeping
them all up to date and patched what
we've done for GCE has built this
technology called live migration this is
not like you know we didn't invent a
technology like VMware has been doing
you know their own version of live
migration they call it V motion for many
years but we're like the first public
cloud hyperscale provider to do live
migration at the scale that we're doing
lab migration like obviously we run lots
and lots of VMs across many many zones
and we use live migration quite a bit to
make sure that all of our underlying
systems and our are patched and updated
and and all without disrupting the vm so
what a lot of migration does is it
basically your vm is running on one host
machine and let's say we got to take
that host machine offline to do a kernel
host Colonel upgrades
what we do is we you know trigger live
migrations for the VMS that are running
on that host machine and what a live
migration does is while the vm is
running it starts copying the state over
it creates a new like virtual machine
target on a different host starts
copying all of the state like Ram the
the via the specification for the vm the
machine type all of the different PQ no
PDS and things like that network
connections basically creates a exact
mirror of that virtual machine on a
different host and then at once we've
copied the majority of the state we
pause the the source vm briefly and then
unpause it i'll copy the rest of the
remaining state and then unpause it on
the target and now that vm is now
running on a different host machine
without any impact well you know with
with minor performance in a very brief
brown a very brief blackout window which
is what we call that pause period that
it's actually paused doing that last
transition and and you know that that's
for most applications like that pause
has is completely invisible likey and
and the purport there is like very
little performance degradation for the
majority of our our our virtual machines
and so most customers just go what go
don't even you know their workloads
don't even notice that we've done this
and and you know it's it's very very
powerful compared to the alternative
which is essentially scheduling reboots
and you know oh we need to roll out a
security patch for the like than the
latest heartbleed you know vulnerability
or whatever and so that required you
know our our competition to reboot like
a significant chunk of their their
customers VMs and so there was like this
huge flurry of activity if you're a
customer there that where you had to go
basically figure out when the best time
you're going to be able to reboot in the
next few days because the machines that
were running on that you're vemos were
running on were vulnerable and then
Google did the same thing we patched all
of our host machines but we did it all
using live migrations so we didn't have
to require any reboots excellent oh that
sounds like super interesting stuff I
have to ask this though feel free to
dodge the answer I totally understand um
what sort of new features could we
possibly be seeing for compute engine I
know we had next recently we had a bunch
of announcements there but can you hint
at anything you touch fun anything I
would
be doing my job if I didn't ask yeah
sure I can I can talk in general terms
like so at G as you mentioned gcp the
most recent and gcp next we had down in
San Francisco we did talk about the fact
that we're going to be adding more
regions and zones over the next few
years and so you know we we are very
serious about like continuing to expand
our footprint across into more regions
that are that our customers are asking
for and that provide you know the
locality that that different workloads
require and so the the first two of
those areas that we're expanding to is
going to be Oregon and Japan later this
year and then you know obviously in 2017
there's good we're going to be expanding
into even more areas more regions so
we'll be opening up new Regents and
zones and that's going to be a huge
advantage benefit to customers so that
they can run their workloads where it
makes the most sense and is where that
well near where their their users happen
to be so that's one of the big things
that we're doing over the next couple
years and without getting too specific
you know we are also working on features
that make it easier to troubleshoot your
VMs you know kind of like that hot hot
grow PD thing that we talked about like
you know if something goes wrong with
the vm when it's booting up like it's
often very challenging to figure out
what went wrong and so we're working on
tools to make that a lot easier again
think think the hot grow analogy where I
just click a few buttons or call an API
and it's solved this is somewhat similar
like you try to make it as simple as
possible to to figure out what went
wrong and fix it without having to do
the whole dance of you know deleting the
vm without deleting the disc attaching
the disc to another vm figuring out
what's the problem and you know
basically there's this whole sequence
it's a real pain right now and we want
to make that easier and then also the
other another thing we want we're
working on our kind of more enterprise
friendly pricing and usage models you
know enterprises have quite a huge
spectrum of requirements when it comes
to how they do budgeting and how they
figure out what they're going to spend
their money their budgets on and that
sort of thing and so so more enterprise
friendly pricing
are definitely something that we're
working on to be able to make it easier
for more enterprises to to easily shift
stuff over to cloud platform and then
obviously we continue you know doing the
we like turning the crank on the the
bigger faster cheaper you know computing
so so that's those are in general terms
and and if you're anybody out there
who's evaluating GCE and/or gcp in
general and you want to hear more about
some specific details you know please
reach out to me on Twitter and we can
have a much more low-level chat and much
more detailed chat under NDA so cool
well I think we're pretty much running
out of time but is there anything else
that you would like to mention some
topics that we may have missed um I
think the like the biggest thing that
that you know I want to make sure I if I
could send everyone away with you no one
to do or one action I would say check
out cloud google com you know if you
haven't yet if you you know this is the
first time you're hearing that Google
has a cloud platform hopefully not
because you know you've got some regular
podcast subscribers and so people are
familiar with it but tell your friends
check out like our website there's a ton
of amazing products that we have data
and analytics machine learning your
basic GCE your App Engine which is just
write your code and deploy it and forget
about it and and pretty much everything
in between and it's it's a compra very
comprehensive platform and and we're
really really pleased to see the growth
that we're seeing but but we would love
it if we love more always love more
customers and and so please check it out
all right well thank you very much for
joining Scott was not sleep pleasure to
talk to you it was great talking with
you guys too thanks for having me again
thank you fence again this scott van
wouldn't work for such an interesting
conversation yeah really enjoyed it it's
good to see you know people still
talking about the basic building blocks
at the cloud yeah virtual machines are a
real thing yea though they're called
virtual so yeah very interesting let us
know if you have any questions we have
the contact information for Scott on the
show notes and apparently he's very keen
on getting your questions and opinions
yeah and we're always looking for more
questions of the week to say you know
absolutely yes
and talk about questions of the week
let's go with a question of the week
that these for this episode come from no
I'm Franco and he says hi Frances a mark
it's a great post and podcast you have
thank you thank you very much and
basically he says he listened to the
episode on humblebundle and we mentioned
so and the actual mentioned that they
were backing up data store to be query
via Google Cloud storage and he's
basically asking what is this magic how
does this work right so I had a look
into this it's it's actually kind of
interesting there have been ways to back
up data store for a long time a lot of
them have been fairly manual so we've
got some links to the show notes there
is a way you can go in and enable the
data store admin and then go from there
to back up all of your data store data
in one big go there's no incremental
backup but you can take the whole thing
and say okay I want these particular
kinds within data store and then sort
just put those in a storage bucket I'm
from there once you've got that it's
relatively trivial to be able to point
at that data store back up inside cloud
storage and say hey bigquery can you
ingest this place one of the cool things
to note is that you can do scheduled
backups they are full backups though so
keep that in mind with like your quotas
and how much you want to be reading and
writing from your data store so you can
do it with a cron from specifying a
chrome file on App Engine like you can
totally do that it's a little bit of
custom code yeah but you can get that up
and running depending on how often you
want to be doing these these full
backups of this data but yeah then you
can take those backups you can ingest
those into bigquery either through the
admin or through the API and then you
can access those that data from bigquery
and do your analytics and all that sort
of fun stuff yeah nothing really fancy
really just a bunch of things that you
need to plug one to each other and then
everything just works everything should
just work so yeah I mean like that the
admin will create jobs for you and run
through like task queues and other sort
of stuff in the background it's worth
noting yeah like I said it's not it's
not incremental it's full backups so if
for example you're getting multiple
ends they could be out of sync a little
bit so you know it's not going to take a
complete snapshot so you sort of have to
take that into account but for stuff
you're pointing to bigquery I'm thinking
that's probably less less important yeah
I guess that if you really wanted
something that good do it weekly or
daily or something like that you could
always build your own thing that could
generate that like it could just create
just a query of all the data that was
created during the last day or so but
you're gonna have to do more manual
things if you everything you're going to
do is the whole thing and just don't the
whole thing on to be quiet yeah sounds
like a good idea in some cases this also
could push towards like a good argument
for using things like pub sub yes so
that you know when you go to store your
data it goes through data but another
subscriber maybe pics that data up
shoves it off into bigquery as well and
then you can keep that data alive in
there and have multiple things do stuff
based on on those actions and pops ups
are really grateful for that yeah I'm a
little bit cool so before we finish why
don't we discuss well why don't we talk
about our next plans what are you going
to be doing what am I going to be doing
so this week we still have changed the
game here in San Francisco very excited
for that what they thought that is a
game conference we're running here in
San Francisco we're gonna have a bunch
of customers come by some Googlers I am
co-presenting twice so I guess that
means I'm doing one presentation so
talking about multiplayer games
analytics for games all sorts of cool
stuff it's going to be a really fun
event I know there's going to be a bunch
of Googlers around as well I will be
there which I'm sure it just makes it
extra extra special I really like that
my question was actually what day is
that but you don't undersell what day is
that sorry I thought you said what's
going on there no no what what they what
they all day what I wanna die that is on
friday so i'll go gym couple of days yes
couple of days after the podcast comes
out cool yeah after that i will be
presenting at GD g Twin Cities for their
made up i will be at open source north i
will be at dev objective and then i'll
be in new york for a gaming panel at
towards the end the month I've got all
the details of that yet Wow yeah I'm
doing some travel this month it's but
he's eating crazy yeah yeah and then I'm
taking
birkin spending a week in New York
because nice why not I know you're
preparing for your long biking ride yes
I'm going to be biking from San
Francisco to Los Angeles and I'm leaving
on Sunday so next week I'm gonna spend
my whole week on a bike very excited
we're excited gladly scared but it's
gonna be fun based on your level of
sunburn looks like you're well prepared
yeah yeah that was from yesterday yeah
yeah and after that I'm gonna be taking
a couple weeks of relaxing and writing
stuff and trying to be more productive
without troubling and after that i will
go to gopher come excellent yeah but
does in july so we have a couple weeks
of recording podcast before that
absolutely well thank you so much for
joining me today yeah thank you so much
for joining me as well as desk and talk
to you next week i'll speak to you next
week
you